for all the talk about dedicated virtual
reality companies like oculus or valve
the company that actually probably
brought the most people to the
technology was Google thanks to its
super cheap cardboard viewer that way
you drop in your phone and get in on VR
at rock-bottom prices
now Google is introducing its daydream
VR platform with the view which is a $79
headset that takes the promise of the
cardboard and makes it much more
comfortable now as you can see this
thing is basically like the fleece
jogger of VR headsets the face mask is
removable and actually hand washable but
it's not just they're following sculpted
there's a little bit of light leakage
but not too much and really it cuts down
on getting that impression that a VR
headset can leave on your face whether
that's a mobile driven headset or a PC
driven one and a very very easy simple
fabric strap in order to use it just
like any other mobile VR solution you
turn on your phone and then here drop it
in if all goes according to plan it
pairs via NFC you open it it kind of
auto aligns and there's nothing to do
and put it on you connect the controller
pairs via bluetooth and you are ready to
go it's pretty constrained it's still a
mobile VR solution and what that means
is you can look from side to side you
can look up and down you can tell your
head but you can't move forward you're
not positionally track you're not going
to be able to move within virtual space
but just by virtue of having this
controller which can be anything in the
home environment it's essentially a
laser pointer that lets you select the
apps you want to use if you're playing
in a game that can turn into a wand in
other things it can be a flashlight now
as for the stuff that's available on day
one it's really a mix of Google's own
apps and third-party so on the Google
side you have YouTube VR you have Google
Streetview you have a whole suite of
arts and culture experiences that can
take you inside a museum and then on the
third-party side you've got small games
and lightweight puzzle games and RPGs
starchart which is kind of
an astronomy exploration experience more
and more things are coming you know even
even now Netflix and HBO now and who are
all coming if they're not here already
on day one and there's a ton of other
there's like 40 other things that are
coming between now and the end of the
year so this is an ecosystem that's
going to be growing very quickly and
it's also an ecosystem of phones and
headsets are going to be growing very
quickly while right now is just the
daydream view and it only works with the
pixel which is only available on Verizon
there are a number of Android phone
manufacturers that are making their next
phones daydream ready and so as time
goes on there are going to be more
phones that you can use in the daydream
view and maybe even some of their head
says they're going to be able to use
those phones in but for now if you have
a pixel already or your Verizon
customers thinking about getting one and
for $79 a day dream view is a pretty
nice and comfortable way in